好，咱开始今天的课程啊。
上节课说到哪儿了？
拿事儿说话。
就说咱之前学会了讲故事。
我也让大家写了个故事，以千来字包含八要素，记得吧？
那个玩意儿其实叫啥呢？在咱们剧本创作中啊，那个东西叫梗概。
然后我承诺大家。
有了梗概之后呢。
呃，教大家写剧本。
但其实在梗概跟剧本之间，还有一样东西叫大纲。
叫大纲。
上节课跟大家简单说了是吧？
就是这个梗盖。
到剧本之间。
还有一个东西叫大纲啊。
梗概呢我们说一一般是1000来字，1500字左右。剧本呢4万到6万不等。
大纲呢万把字儿一两万吧。
就这么个规模，有些同学说了，那非得写完梗概，非得再写一个大纲，大纲，你又不拿去卖去，大纲也卖不了钱，谁也不看，是你自己看，对吧？按理说梗概都不应该写，直接干剧本多好。
或者是说我们简单拉个梗盖直直接干剧本呗。
为啥会有个大纲这一步呢？
必须得有我上节课跟大家说了，梗盖的时候，其实你写的那个玩意儿啊。
还是有点像作文。
或者是一个小小说。
到大纲上节课叫啥来着？拿事儿说话。
到大纲，我只要事儿。
只要事儿。
上节课我给大家举个例子吧。
你写了，你说老。
老什么呢？老李啊老李这个人呢。
外表冷漠，内心狂热。
这个是。
你可以在梗概里面这么说。
到大纲，你给我打住，你给我打住，外表冷漠，内心狂热。
你让我咋拍？假设我现在是导演，我就问你，你让我咋拍？
事儿上见。
你要想说他外表冷漠，内心狂热，你拿一个事儿给我。
对不对？
事儿上去。
你说老李外表冷漠，内心狂热，是因为他年少的时候命运多舛，你再给我打住。他年少的时候命运多舛，你拍还是不拍？
你要拍给我写上。
他小时候。
从哪里切到他小时候。
对吧。
是他看着老照片开始回忆，还是通过他妈的嘴，他妈口述，对吧？老人口述说，哎，这孩子啊年轻的时候啊，命运多舛，这这也是个办法。但是你得给我事儿上见。
这就是我上节课跟大家说的这个大纲。
为什么必须有？
就是这个道理，他把你梗盖。
你当时。
信笔一挥。
写的那些玩意儿拿事儿给我实现。
不管是他外表冷漠，内心狂热，还是他年少时命运多舛。
这些话写小说都可以，小说里面经常有这种啊，你是个男主角，对吧？你随便写他什么。
呃这这些描述性的东西，大家只要能理解，大家就接受啊。当这个男主角是这样的人。
但是你作为一个剧本，你最终全部是用画面。
画面和声音呈现这个玩意儿。
你所有的故事，所以你这些。
梗概里面的这些这些词儿，这些这些你想要的元素，其实是你传想传达的信息，对吧？你必须在大纲里面全部给我变成事儿，就是上节课的意思就是拿事儿说话，或者说呢叫全部变成。
要么是。
这个环境的描述。
对吧。
要么是环境的描述，要么是动作。
要么是对白。
就基本上你得用这三样东西去给我表达你想要传达的那些信息。
环境假设你原本的梗概率员，你写这个男主角呢？
不修边幅。
生活上呢很随性，那你可能就通过他的。
居住环境。
他穿的衣服。
来把这个信息传达一下子。
那就是在大纲里面，你要你要知道你你有这个信息是要完成的。然后他的动作他做的事情对吧？然后他跟别人发生的对白，就这三样武器。
去表达你梗概里面想要表达的那些信息。我为什么让大家先写梗概，先写八要素，就是你想把你传达的东西，你先都写下来。
按照逻辑写下来，到了大纲这里，实际上大纲我上节课说了，其实是接近于剧本的。
大纲已经很接近于剧本了。
我们先写大纲，就是把你梗概里面承诺想要表达的那些信息，用这三种方法。
全过表达。
也就是说事儿上见这三种方法为什么只有这三种方法？因为这三种方法。
都是可以用画面表达的。
那是拍影视剧呀，毕竟不是写小说，这其实就是小说家和编剧最大区别就在这儿，咱们能用的武器少。
他们可以描写。
对吧就我说的那个这个这个老李小时候命运多舛，他可以写。
他可以写，他信笔就写，对吧？他说这个老李外表冷漠，内心狂热，心笔就写。然后呢，他说这个老李呃呃这个跟他老婆貌合神离，他随便就写。但问题你貌合神离，你你不给我事儿。
我怎么拍人家貌合审离，你得给我个事儿描述一下他们俩人的状态，这就是最大的区别。所以咱这节课呢。
这三样东西呃大纲就是说必须用画面来开始用从大纲开始必须用画面讲故事了。咱们这节课就叫勾勒画面，好吧。
咱这节课就叫勾勒的画面。
然后我上节课呀给大家拉了一下。
所谓的四目式记得吗？
既然要拿事说话，那都写些什么事儿呢？这不就是又来一个又来一个难点了吗？大家好不容易把梗概掌握了，现在要写大纲了，又出难点了。
咱先不说这个字数上的难点，一下从1000字扩到1万字。但其实你要真把信息都传达了，一万字都不够。
我上节课给大家说了，咱们的四目式记得吗？
记得四模式吗？三模式是建制冲突解决对吧？然后冲突那分成两个部分，就是推进。
赚着了。
然后呢。
其实就暗合我们的。
启程转合，我们就用咱们中国人说的启程转合比较好理解，好吧。
假设啊。
来，我们从这儿开始啊，假设。
这是我们的故事线，好吧。
我们说起。
我们把它一分为四，好吧，从时间上就是一分为四嘛。
记得吧？
转。
和。
我们说假设。
时间上一分为4。
一条线性故事启成转合。
我昨天给大家说了。
起成转合。
四段儿。
打三个点。
再加上两头。
五件事儿。
对吧。
我们说开场一件事儿。
这里是高潮一件事儿。
记得吧？
开场一件事儿高潮一件事儿。而且我跟大家说过，开场。
必须是事件。
事儿上开。
结束必须是高潮，一个电影推到最高的时候把它收掉。
然后中间三个打点是什么来着？
激励。
这个词应该是大家的老朋友了啊，很熟悉了啊。
然后。
这里是什么？
转折。
记得吗？
这里是什么？
危机。
我们说你看啊。
一个故事如果分四段。
分四段，那就是打5个点。
那就是开场一件事儿，激励一件事儿，转折一件事，危机一件事儿高潮一件事儿，这就有5件事儿。
但是五件事儿当中。
这块怎么度过呢？
我们把它填满。
好了？
这里呢概念性的东西会有一些，但是我一定咱们叫实战课程，我一定给大家举例子，带着大家学会这些东西，大家不要觉得它枯燥，好吧，没有问题的，启程转合四目式。
用5件。
一般来说啊一般来说我们说启承转合是木。
对不对？木这叫木。
这是一个剧本最大的。
单位叫木。然后呢，我们说最后这个剧尾呈现出来的最小单位是什么来着？是场。
然后呢，在木跟长。
之间你不可能说我写四目，我先起一个事儿乘一个事，转一个事儿，合一个事儿，四个事儿就把剧本干下来了，那是不可能的对吧？你不可能按照这四个去写场。
那我们在木根厂之间还有一个过渡单位，一般来说啊叫序列。
也就是说把木再细化一下。
再细分一下。
然后呢，这样的话便于你。
左手。
往里填内容了。
一般来说叫序列。好吧，如果你在其他的教材上看到一些节拍的啊也是也是也有那么叫的，大家不要觉得陌生，是这样啊。
我在这里插一句话啊。
边去教学。
虽然是技术，我我一直坚持认为编剧教学。
是先学技术，在技术的基础上。
去发展艺术。
但是它毕竟是一个技术跟艺术相结合的东西。
所以呢。
他永远没有一个。
非常确定的。
百分之百正确的那种方式方法。
他就像奥运会一样。
奥运会上，你说来赛跑哗跑。
刘翔赢没赢，得没得第一，一目了然。
对不对？赢了就是赢了，跑的最快的那个就他就在前头。
这种呢就属于竞技性的竞技体育。
一目了然。
然后剧本这个东西呢，你说有没有技术，也有也有谁强强谁弱。但是呢它有点像艺术体操，就你做完了之后呢。
这个胜负需要。
大家去评判。
对吧而且呢因人而异，有些人就觉得那个你跳的更好。
所以这个这个它就是在这儿。
所以剧本这个东西呢也是这样。
他有没有高下之分？
有有没有高下好坏，当然有，但是是不是就是那么的。
不好说。
所以剧本教学也是这样，刘派挺多的，说法挺多的。有些人呢就认这一门，有些人呢认那一门互相之间文人相亲就瞧不上。我跟你讲，只有文人才相亲，5人没有相亲的。你如果说五人相亲，你就插这个腰，他刘霞刘霞算个屁，那刘霞肯定说来来。
来，咱俩这跑跑。
对吧掐这个腰说哎哎呀，张伟丽张伟丽你这算个什么呀？我上去都能笑了。张伟丽肯定说，那来咱俩打一场。
对吧就是文人相亲，武人没有相亲的，你相亲，他揍你。
对吧所以说咱们这个编剧啊。
你会看到很多很多的说法，包括这个序列啊。
我说你看啊五四目式五个风向事件加上序列，我给你填上之后会是10个序列。
也有人不同意的，也有人说，哎，我我细分了一下，我习惯写13个序列。还有人说我习惯用八序列。
都有。
你们先不用去受受干扰。我呢每种方法我都研究过，我给你们讲出来的就是便于大家最容易理解，最最容易。
展开工作的我们为啥叫实战嘛？对吧？我们从实战角度出发。
大家不要去困惑，我知道有很多人就是看比较现在这几年比较流行的那种节牌器那种书。那个我后面会给大家讲它有什么优点和缺点。在这里呢，我们先按照序列去理解一个故事，因为这是最传统的。
好吧，废话就说这么多，我们接着说序列。
我们说你看啊这5个部分其实是管着你起承转和骨节上的。
关节位置的事儿等于呢它是。
相当于风向标就到路口了，往哪走，它是路口的事儿，但是路上你不是。
你还得有事儿吗？
所以把它补上好吧，把它补上来。
开场到激励之间，这儿呢叫切入。
只成切人了呢。
75啊。
切入实界。
激励到转折之间，这叫进展事件。
转折到危机之间。
叫再转。
世界。
危机到高潮之间。
叫导入事件。
然后这是9个。
记得我跟大家说过一句话吧。
这个在最早的第三课第四课的时候，我说过你所有的东西写完之后啊。
赠送大家一个结局。
结局是送的，因为他已经无关大局了，但是必须要有为什么呢？他是观众情绪最后的一个。
安放点。
对吧就是我给大家举的那个例子，那个一个想要殉职的警察，他把所有的主题所有的故事都实现，都讲完了之后，至于他最后死没死。
就根据当时的情绪。
送给观众这个。
让观众情绪宣泄一下。所以呢最后有一个在高潮后面又续一个结局。
他是私募以外的。
是赠送的。
你看看。
是不是十件事儿？
10个。
这就叫序列。
1个序列。
我们这一项。
就妥了，你要10个序列。
写明白了，那你这剧本大纲就妥妥的，妥妥的。
我们看这十0个序列，我跟他为什么5个5个给大家讲呢？你看啊隔一个跳一个是比较重要的。
开场激励转折、危机高潮。
都是硬词儿。另外5个呢切入一下，进展一下，再转一下，导入一下，对吧？都是过渡型的。
所以说。
这10个序列我们明白。
就可以。
往上填肉。
填故事了。
我们先来看一下这10个序列，从定义上它都负责些什么，好吧，我们说这10个。
1个序列，其中5个是。
风向型的路标型的路口的那事儿。
比较重要。
然后另外5个呢是服务。
风向事件的。
开场主要负责什么呢？其实开场他需要交代主角的身份、环境、基本情况，这些是肯定的，这些是必须要交代的。第一场是必须要把这些事情做做掉的，就说这是一个什么样的世界观。
这个世界是一个什么样的世界？这个主角是一个什么样的主角？他呢基本的问题，他人物的身份，包括他那个附加值的身份描述全部要在第一场。
开场里面半掉的。
所以开场戏除了交代信，他大量的向观众传输信息以外，它的作用。
那个是他的责任，传输信息是它的基本责任，但它的作用其实是引起兴趣。
引起大家观看的兴趣啊。
你这才是你第一场戏。
需要做到的事情，传达信息，那是及格线，好吧。
然后激励事件。
是什么呢？激励事件是核心问题展现，这核心问题的发端呢。
就是你核心要处理的那个事儿，在激利事件出来了，有可能是激励出来的。
对吧就是激励出来的嘛。
那么开场到激励事件这个切入是啥意思呢？切入事件是除了继续。
延续。
这个主角的。
各种信息。
延续和强化他的信息。
更主要的是什么呢？铺垫这个吉理事件。
是一个铺垫作用。
转折事件。
那字面上理解，那肯定就是个转折嘛。
但是呢在这里它的最重要的体现形式是什么呢？是主角。
我们提供的那些核心信息，那些信息提供的关于主角的那些信息，有一个一有一个重要因素发生。
方向上或者程度上的转变，就是有一个重要的因素要变。
一个因素改变。
才能导致这个转折。所以在这里一定要有一个。
因素因素改变了。
那出现核心问题到。
有一个重要因素改变之间的这个进展是什么呢？
往往就是我们说的。
依次动作。
就是。
主角在。
被激励了以后。
开始做的。
那些无效的。
尝试。
其实是所以他这里啊。
做的一些无效。
的事情。
然后那在转折下面紧接着一个路标型的事件，就是危机。
危机很容易理解。
就是。
主角遇到的最大考验或者是对手最强的。
攻击的时候。
最大考验。
遇到最大考验的时候，就是这个危机。
那么在转折。
到最大危机。
一个因素发生改变了。
导致转折，但是他在到达最大的考验，最大的危机当中。
发生了什么事呢？
往往就是。
主角铤而走险。
往往就是主角铤而走险。
或者叫主角放手一搏。
在这里。
就是因为因素改变，为什么叫再转，主角也进行了策略上的调整。
他来应对这个改变。
他应对因素的改变自己也做出改变。
所以一般是是这么个玩意儿。
然后最大的考验。
下一个风向路标的这个事件是高潮，高潮是个啥玩意儿呢？高潮其实就是核心问题的解决。
就是核心问题的解决。
就是高潮。
然后呢，在最大的考验和核心问题解决之前之间。
那就是一个导入事件，其实是。
增强情绪烈度的。
就是让这个危危机和到高潮解决之前。
大家就都在考虑这个最大的危机和最后最后的解决这个情绪烈度。
在这里煽风点火，其实是这么个作用，让观众更着急，增加一个烈度。
这里。
然后最后。
给一个结局。
我们说是赠送了，其实是帮助。
帮助观众安放情绪。
我们不是说过吗？那个那个殉职的那个警察，你最后是让他死，还是让他活，让他抓住坏人，还是让他没抓住坏人，甚至说不光让他活，还让他得到一段美好的爱情。那个结局我我说过呃都行，看情况。
为啥就是看情绪，其实是就是看到那儿之后，这个观众这是情绪。
在一个什么样的一个程度上。
所以你看啊。
咱们就是假了。
私幕式里面。
起成转合来切。
有5个。
5个路标型的。
路标型的事件在坎节上。
然后还有5个。
过渡性的事件组成了。
10个序列。
你根据根据这10个序列完成这10个序列的任务，那么你这个大纲就有了。
当然了，这些都是事儿。我上集说过，事儿上见大纲事儿上见，因为他们必须能勾勒出画面。
要么是什么样的一个环境场景画面。
要么是角色采取了一个什么样的行动？
要么是角色之间的。
对白。
全部用画面来去。
有没有例外呢？就画面以外的东西呢。
有。
你们早晚要问，我就给你们讲一讲，有两样东西是在画面以外的。
一个是。
叫旁白。
或者叫白呀。
因为他有时候不是旁白，有时候是。
主角自己在那摆。
内心独白。比如说。
这是一种。
还有一种呢。
就闪回。
或者回忆其实闪回是能用画面拍出来的。但是我为什么把它跟跟旁白是归在一块儿呢？就这两样的东西。
我非常不推荐大家用。
至少现阶段。
别用。
为什么啊？
你说有的成功作品里有没有这些。
有一些牛逼的电影电视剧里面有这两样东西。
但是那都都是什么情况下啊？
就是你的信息量，你一个影片所传达的信息点。
过于多，你的画面都装不下。
然后这时候作家或者是创作者选择了用。
一部分白。
来表达这个意思。
这是被允许的这是被允许，而且被理解。
被赞赏的。
因为他给我们的东西太多了。
明白吧？
就像饭店来上菜。
一盘子龙虾，一盘子螃蟹，然后呢跟你说，哎呦，这儿有几只鲍鱼，盘子里面装不下了，我拿了个小碟儿盛给你行吗？虽然有失体统，但是我们说这拿来拿来挺好拿来。
是不是啊？
明白这个意思吗？
但是你不能说来你你好家伙，你写个剧本，你的画面空空，细息聊聊。然后呢，你跟客人说哎。
这个呃我我给你上点呃上一个西红柿炒鸡蛋，对吧？拿小碟儿盛给你。
那客人肯定生气啊，客人说你那大盘子空着给我看呢。
你上了两个大空盘子，然后告诉客人，我没有地方装了，我拿小碟给你盛点菜，我拿骨碟给你盛点，那肯定有失体统嘛。
明白这个意思吗？
就是说。
人家那种片子是因为信息量太。
所以用一点。
而且一般来说也用于用来交代。
环境的变迁或者年代的变迁，对吧？
30年以后什么什么什么。
就用点旁白，你用画面很难表现30年过去了。
对吧或者是。
1942年的那个冬天。
比以往来的更冷。
河南的农民踏上了逃荒的路。
这时候你用点白交代一下，否则大家看不出来这是哪年，这是些农民的桃荒，对吧？你用点可以那种都是。
高手高阶选手用的。
包括闪回，我们说老李小时候命运多舛。
闪回为啥有些有些呃牛逼的戏也用。
那些而且那个戏啊你去看啊，基本上都是通过小说呀，或者是通过别的文体改过来的。他有时候信息量确实是装不下了。你如果说是一个剧本，我就准备写一个剧本。
你还加骨蝶儿。
你要做多少菜，你心里没数吗？
我非常不推荐初学者用，你先老老实实把故事讲好。
可以用回忆。
没问题，回忆是可以用的，但别给我用闪回。就是我这儿需要一个之前的信息了。好家伙，我蹭的一下就往前闪一下，就为了交代我这个人小时候命运多舛，没有必要没有必要。
这是这个有些同学有可能会产生的疑问，好吧。
我们刚才说到哪儿了？咱们从大纲开始就是用这三样东西去去开始讲了。
全是可视化的。
对吧你全是能拍出来的，全是画面。为什么人家说编剧说话比小说家会有画面感，因为你们写每一。
段每一场的时候，你脑子里面装的全是画面，没有画面就不要写。
没有画面不要写。
对吧我记得我以前曾经在。
一个剧本里我自己的例子啊。
剧本里写过这么一段话，说我今天去朋友家做客。
朋友一对情侣，一对夫妻吧，一对小夫妻。我一推门一进去，他俩。
抬头跟我打了一下招呼，打了个招呼，他们俩都是我朋友嘛。然后呢。
虽然看起来没有什么异常，但是我感觉到他们俩刚吵过架。
这种情况有没有？
有吧，咱们生活里经常有，所以一推门发现哎。
两个人好像吵架了。
然后我就在剧本里写了这么这么一场戏。
来。
你让导演咋拍？
你感觉到他俩好像吵过架。
你用内心独白吗？咦，他们俩是不是吵过架了，你只能用内心独白去表达，这就是我说的，不要这样做很low这点信息。
对吧你这么写就是不负责任，因为你拍不出来，然后你写内心独白呢就是low。
那你说这种情况怎么办？
你就得描述给导演或者描述给工作人员，你想表达我能感觉出他俩人吵过架。
那他俩的坐姿。
地上的物品。
他俩说话的语气。
然后他们正在观看的电视节目。
他俩抬头看我时候的眼神儿。
我接到这个信息之后，我的反应你把这些描述出来。
让观众跟着你一起感觉到，我操他俩好像真的是吵过架了，这才行，明白这个意思吗？不要不负责任的写，我感觉他俩好像吵过架了，那观众感觉不到。
这是不负责任。
然后呢，说那我写写成内心独白，对吧？我我这个主角往里一进，内心独白，咦，他们俩是不是吵过架了，这是low。
才驴于地球，不要这么做。
好不好？描述出来。
不难描述出来，这就是发挥我们本领的时候。
我跟大家说，这素材，平常积累的那些素材调用一下呀，你生活中每一个人都有去别人家里一推门，感觉气氛不太对，对方好像吵过架，每个人都有这样的经历。你下次经历这种事情的时候，好好观察一下，是什么触发了你这个感受。
对吧肯定不是地上一滩雪，那还有个菜刀，那不是刚刚吵过架，那是出大事的，你赶紧报110。
肯定不是这么大的症仗的一个描述，对吧？就是一些微小的一个眼神，或者是坐姿。
对吧或者是他们说话的语气，平常你你去了，他们都是说哎，你来了。
那个呃做。
说四个字儿。
今天是来了。
俩字儿。
那不是这区别不就来了吗？
就就能感受到气氛的不对了。
这只是举个例子，好吧，就是说你。
从大纲开始，你的每一笔都要负起责任，负起什么责任，负起一个勾勒画面的责任，不要写那种没有画面的事儿了。
没有画面的话，一句也不要写了。那写写一些什么样的事儿呢？你写事儿，你得跟着脉络走呀，1个脉络。
每一段的责任。
大家明白了吗？
不是很明白。
确实这一部分呢就是概念性的东西多。
但是我们必须去这么学。我上一节课跟大家说过啊，我说这是个横轴。
这是个横轴啊。
这是根据时间画的轴。
我之前教过大家，我们说讲故事有八要素。
对吧。
我说按照八要素可以完整的讲出一个故事梗概。
什么样的人？
产生了一个什么样的欲望？
通过一个什么样的动作去实现？
遇到了一个什么样的核心问题？
对吧实现这个问题的过程中，重重的阻碍是什么？最后得到了一个什么样的结果？
在这个得到这个结果以后呢，正价值战成了负价值。
八要素。
对不对？
那么我们来说现在写大纲的时候，时间轴是启成转和，是这个序列。那我们的八要素何去何从呢？
八要素就是我们的纵轴。
纵轴。
你看啊。
这是10个核心事件。
这是10个核心事件的。
作用。
然后我们的八样素。
分成三大要素的话。
就是人物。
世接。
主题。
然后人物是什么来着？
身份。
欲望。
动作。
问题。
主力。
结果。
主题正价值。
副驾驶对吧？
我们说你把你原本的八要素放在纵轴上。
然后。
让他实现。
他在。
每一个环节内。
序列横轴序列内每一个环节内的作用。
比如说他的身份。
上来。
开场画面里面，哎呦，我们应该往写的那一排啊，来开场画面里面。
他的身份。
他的第一身份必须交代。
必须交代。
这时候他会有一个身份。
对吧。
我们说。
在。
转折这里他的身份。
也是会发生变化的。
他开起始欲望是什么？终点的欲望是什么？后点的欲望是什么？
就是说把你的八要素在横横轴里面找到各自的位置。
你之前的梗概。
结合你。
新的10个序列事件。
就可以形成一个很立体的。
表格式的。